welcome to iOS 16 where you have two
minutes to unsend a message
and eight different fonts to choose from
for your lock screen's time and a whole
bunch of other hidden features
but you still can't set multiple timers
hey Siri set a two minute timer
no
set another one nope just set another
one crazy
it's that time of the year again when
Apple releases its big iphone update and
this year there are a lot of new
features many of them overdo you just
have to know where to look for them so I
am here to help with my top 10 tips for
iOS 16. let's go actually we're not
going anywhere we're just going to be
right here with our phones poking at
their screens number one redesign your
lock screen here's what your old iPhone
looks like
lame now here's what it can look like
so many choices hold down on the lock
screen tap customize to adjust your
current screen you can change the font
of the time and then the color of the
date and the time there are legit
thousands of colors to choose from
there's even a dropper to match the
color to a color in your photo you can
also press the plus button here to get
lots of preset lock screen options from
Apple you can always tweak them to your
liking too it's a hair past 330.
literally my hair is covering the 330.
you can also add widgets like the
weather so you don't always have to
swipe into your phone or look out a real
window
and you can adjust the wallpaper in all
sorts of awesome and weird ways
number two display battery life
percentage okay quick iPhone history
lesson when Apple removed the home
button with the iPhone 10 it removed the
battery percentage from the upper corner
it was horrible every day we had to
swipe down to see the battery percentage
but not anymore go to settings
battery and toggle on battery percentage
ah a hundred percent
number three Mark messages as unread I
know it happens to you all the time you
get a message you say you'll respond
later and then you totally forget about
it or at least that's what I'm telling
myself about why you never respond to my
messages but now on a message chain hold
down and hit Mark as unread or swipe to
the right and then tap here
number four unsend or edit messages
sometimes you make a typo and now you
can fix it in messages long press on a
message you didn't mean to send and tap
undo send it will remove the message
from the chain so long as the others are
running iOS 16 and later you only have
two minutes after sending to use this
feature prefer to edit that message long
press and select edit you'll be able to
edit the text the receiver will be able
to see what was edited and see the
previous text you can edit messages
within 15 minutes of sending number five
change how notifications are displayed
something terrible has happened
the notifications have moved to the
bottom of the screen yep now they're all
down here but there are three options of
how they can appear number one and the
default is this stack view but swipe up
on it and you get the second option list
view showing more information or you can
swipe down and get number three count
view which is a nice way to avoid being
distracted by those notifications
go to settings notifications to change
the default view
number six remove photo backgrounds in
the photos app tap and hold on the main
subject in a photo you'll automatically
see this glowing effect start to outline
it hit copy and then head to any app
where you can paste a photo hit paste
and there's the subject of your photo
without any background
number seven ADD medication reminders
in the health app go to browse
medications add medications
if you have your medication handy in my
case these eye drops you can scan it
using the camera boom found it it's a
stain complete then you input the day
and time you need to take it should get
this Alert in two minutes we will see
if it works
got my notification
that you all know and if you don't want
Apple to know that you're using eye
drops or whatever other medication
you've added if you have two-factor
authentication enabled on your phone
then all of this information is end to
end encrypted and apple won't be able to
see it number eight merge duplicate
contacts question do I actually have
three dads and need to be on some sort
of Jerry Springer Show or are they just
the same three entries in my contacts in
the contacts app tap view duplicates
select one confirm it's the same person
and hit merge on the bottom to create
one entry with all the information
number nine turn your iPhone into a
webcam hi it's me on my MacBook looking
really good because I'm actually
shooting this with an iPhone 12 Pro okay
this one is a little bit more
complicated and it requires an iPhone
running iOS 16 and a Mac running Mac OS
Ventura which is also due out this fall
make sure you've used the same Apple ID
to log into both devices
enable Wi-Fi and Bluetooth on both
devices too when they're in close
proximity and you're in a video
conferencing app you should see this on
your phone now you'll be able to use the
phone as a wireless webcam and I can
even change Here video effects this is
me in portrait mode
this is with center stage on where it
will automatically find me hey look it
even works in zoom and Belkin is even
going to sell this very cool magsafe
Clip Clips to the back of your iPhone
you can put it right on your laptop
now this is the coolest trick
in the Mac video effects panel you can
click on desk View and it gives you a
view of what's actually on your desk
using the iPhone's Ultra wide camera
okay this is pretty great if you need to
do a demo of something or your virtual
magician
and you need to do a trick
pick a card any card
everyone can see the card and the person
can see the card
my job as a magician is done number 10
schedule or unsend email in Apple Mail
welcome Apple Mail features that Gmail
has had for years in the mail app hold
down on the arrow button to schedule
your email to be sent at another time
and by default Apple will now give you
10 seconds to unsend an email in case
you made a mistake and quickly want to
get that email back
go to settings
mail
undo send delay to turn off the feature
or adjust the length up to 30 seconds
all right I know I said 10 but here are
a few more for the bonus round the
fitness app is now on your iPhone no
need to have an Apple Watch to set a
move goal in the photos app you'll soon
be able to create a shared photo library
so you can automatically share photos
with friends and family without needing
to message them or create a new album
and you can finally dictate your
favorite emojis
poop emoji fart Emoji I said fart Emoji
not heart emoji